you like to play a quick round up truth
or dare
[Applause]
and today we have cat legere
hi cat hello hi
i wanted to i just told you i said i
think that this is one of my favorite
audience member outfits ever thank you
thank you thank you so what's it gonna
be a truth or a dare
truth okay okay so drew have you ever
bribed or flirted your way out of a
ticket
yes
you have give me a story
um well
i don't know if i would flirt per se but
i've definitely come up with a host of
excuses
um and maybe one or two times it worked
and my bunch it didn't i got my license
taken away when i was like 17 because i
had like repeat offenders and then i've
kind of reigned it in after that like
check i bet you'd be so good at it you
just like play with your hair and be
like i'm sorry was that a red light and
i didn't know
[Music]
right either you do this yeah yeah no
it's it's yeah it's sometimes it's
worked sometimes it hasn't yeah we've
all been there right
yeah i have definitely and what did you
do cat i bribed and you wait wait wait
would you bribe
just like a few years ago um i got
pulled over by a cop and when he was
walking over i noticed that he was a cop
that is dating my best friend so when he
came in i was like if you give me this
ticket i am calling her and there's no
more dates after that
he left me out on a warning so that was
good
wow that went well
thank you cats so much great meeting you
guys so great meeting you
[Music]